[MUSIC PLAYING]
Belly's digital loyalty program.
We work with retailers to create
a custom unique loyalty program
and give their
members the ability
to have one card
or app that they
can use at all of our
participating locations.
We were working on
a Friday afternoon
and finally got the app
ready that we actually
thought we could
put it in a business
and actually have it work.
And so we went out
selling that afternoon,
found a local comic book
shop here in Chicago
on a late Friday
afternoon and sold them
on the idea of trying Belly.
They installed the
loyalty program,
and we sat back for the
rest of the night watching
to see if anyone would use it.
And that night, 17 of 20 of
their customers signed up.
We saw two customers come in.
One of the girls
bought a comic book
her friend wasn't going to,
and she heard about the reward
through the loyalty
program where
you could come in 50
times and then punch
the owner in the stomach.
So she walked back
into the store
to buy a comic book
just to sign up.
That's when I think we knew
that we are onto something.
For our product, we
put a tablet customer
facing at the point of
sale of small businesses.
And so for us, when we started,
that tablet app was all native.
And we ran into a number of
different scaling problems
having a native app that's
customer facing inside
of retail businesses, especially
as we started to scale.
And so some of the things
that we've evolved to is--
know that app has now
gone to a hybrid app.
There's a base layer of native
code for some of the hardware
interactions, but the
majority of it's HTML5.
Our infrastructure,
our back end,
is all built on Ruby, Napa.
We started to use
some new technologies
for some of our web and
command center services
that our merchants
use built on Angular.
So we continue to
iterate and continue
to evolve based on some of the
problems or challenges we run
into and new technologies
that arise-- better ways
to use new tools.
But I think that's kind
of the primary stack.